[موسيقى]
أضع سيناترا مع محرر
وهل ستتمكن من الوصول إلى كوما من هذا القبيل
أنا هناك
إجبار allysia أنت وأنا نوظف
وافق على رؤيتك
لا يؤجل الاخرين
عازمة على الحانة ومروحة nanas
نوبات الغضب مشاكل الدماغ عليهم على أي حال
في المنطقة كلها
أن يناموا في الأول وأسفل الألم
لاحظ شوريا لاحقًا أن ألفا سيكون هو
عبد الله نحن أصدقاء ، سأبدأ به
ولكن حان الوقت لأخذ جولة في الدماغ وهم
هل هناك مثل أي مدينة تندم عليها
ليس فقط بلوم
المجموعة في الواقع
استعادة الدولة
مهندس بول
القضبان وتحت أنا لا أثق وألترا بول
josie re fa تحت سقي zalikhanov لكن
بيع شريطنا الجديد على القوس
وعد بالمياه من الطغاة والتجسس الحمضي
سوريا
فندق سوريا جميلة لا أعمدة مشاكل
بؤر مدرس الكفير على سيلفستر يوم
شرق
الشمال الغربي
كنت لا تزال لائقا قليلا وحب sadko و
فيلم chemal harbor nad kochubey but u
وداعا
زيت oleg nechay عن المحكمة قدم أكثر
من الواضح أن اللون الأحمر مثل هذا أو لكن ها هو
قاتل من العرب
تحب أقوى ش
على المواد و Kolya يشفي و
استعادة أمي الصغيرة
شيرو يا مازدا من الطغاة والجدار من uri
نحن فقط قبل بضع سنوات و
انتقلنا قبل بضعة أشهر
سافر هنا في المنطقة التي أنت هنا
أنت الآن وسقطت رؤوسنا
مقذوفات بدون توقف
أنت تعرف جيدًا تلك الجهود
الإجراءات التي لصقها الروس
الجيش بالتعاون مع السوريين
الجيوش من أجل تحقيق هذه الأهداف
ومن أجل إطلاق سراح كبير
جزء من الإقليم وعندما وصلت و
رأيت كل شيء بأم عينيك
لا تحتاج إلى خريطة يطبقها الوضع
لأنك تراها تعود
الحياة السلمية هذا هو الأفضل
مؤشر النجاح
الجيش
نعم يمكننا رؤية تلك النحاسيات في التاسعة
مدنيين ولكن للأسف لسنا كذلك
يمكننا أن نرى أولئك الذين حقا
فعلتها حقا
لأن بعضهم للأسف
مات والبعض منهم الآن كلهم
لا يزال على الجبهة و
كما لاحظت في كل مرة الفرق عندما كنا
المضي قدما والوصول
أي نجاح الوضع يبدأ كل شيء
أكثر وأكثر صعوبة بسبب
للأسف هناك محاولات
استعادة ورفع مستوى أعلى
مرة أخرى الإرهابيين والإرهاب و
لذلك أعتقد أن لديك اليوم
يزور
مهم جدا لمناقشة هؤلاء
العقبات والصعوبات
التي تنشأ عن السياسية
معالجة
وكيف يمكننا التفاعل و
نحقق النجاح معًا
تنسيق أعمالنا ضد
الإرهاب ومرة ​​أخرى أرحب بكم و
شكرا لك على هذه الزيارة